une entrée
rythmée vous êtes venus avec un chien
et alors vous allez parler vous nous
parlez de
propreté animal ce soir dans cette dans
l'émission voilà
[Rires]
il est poli
donc on lui démêle d'abord les poils de
l'eau tiède une bonne ambiance
n'hésitez pas à donner une friandise
à sa serviette peut-être qu'il pense
qu'il va prendre un bain
voilà alors Rocky qui est là qui vous
fait plein de bisous il me semble propre
enfin en tout cas il est très propre et
lui ça lui pose pas de problème le bain
alors lui voilà c'est la particularité
c'est pour ça que j'ai choisi un chien
qui est très propre merci beaucoup en
tout cas à 10 pour toutes ces précisions
n'oublions pas les animaux